brothers and sisters and dear friends
welcome to this video
um now obviously you guys are thinking
okay the title is clickbait
you can kind of say that but there's a
greater message behind it
now why have i named this um i am
jealous of muhammad hijab
now the question is
jealousy is something that affects
everybody
even tamiya may allah have mercy on him
said that everybody suffers from
jealousy
but for those who try to
control it is someone that's dignified
somebody who
is a dignified person who's someone that
tries to control it and somebody who
cannot control it
is referred to as somebody that has no
integrity now
jealousy is something that's affected
adam ali salam's children one had
one overcame the other and killed uh the
his own brother his own blood brother
and we know from banu israel as well
that yakuba islam's children
were envious of yusuf al-islam and that
brought them to the level of wanting to
kill their
own brother now when i first met
muhammad hijab
may allah uh bless him inshaallah i
didn't know him
all i see is the brother who comes to
the park and
in the darwin scene jealousy exists now
not only in the daoism when i was
speaking to my teachers they said that
this is actually more
on a greater scale with the people of
knowledge so the ulama
and be it people who are studying abroad
this is actually more
than a peak on their level now the
reason i'm sharing this reminder with
you guys is because
mohammed james is an example that i'm
giving is because he's someone that's
working with me closely you know
now i could have easily said to myself
you know what i'm ali dawa
i've got this many subscribers this
brother has just come into the scene
and there's this phenomena that goes
about i want you to be
good and i want you to be better but not
better than me
so this is a disease that we have in the
heart where we think to ourself you know
what
i want good for this person as long as
he's never going to be better than me
this is the disease that we carry inside
us and a lot of people who study
and seeking knowledge abroad they are
doing it
with the intentions studying this
knowledge why so they can
be better than this person or they're in
competition with this person or if they
see another student of knowledge doing
better than them
they don't like it and this is a disease
that
covers our um sadly it affects our ummah
why is it that we cannot want the best
for another muslim another believer why
now coming back to prophet muhammad
hijab again and with this inshallah it's
very important that if anybody praises
you to your face
said that make this dua the following
dua is that when somebody comes and
prays it to your face
you say may allah forgive me for what
you do not know about me because you're
only praising me for the mercy of allah
that you do not know my sins
and may allah make me better than what
you think of me
this is a dua that you should always
keep in mind
so i could have come and said you know
what no i don't want to promote him
i don't want to do this no you know he's
more knowledgeable than me
or in these aspects etcetera and he has
his shortcomings and now his brother i
know i spend time with him i have
shortcomings he has a shortcomings that
we advise him and he has his strong
points and his
weak points now the reason i'm
mentioning this is because
to me if my goal is i'm alidawah and i
have to be the person in the in the uh
the light you know like i have to be out
there if the dawah is about me
then i would have a problem with anyone
coming into the scene i would have a
problem with this guy come in
and this person coming and talking about
this but if the dawah is not
from it's not about me and it's about
allah's religion
and making his kalam the highest and
defending his religion against his
enemies
then i should have zero problem with
another believer
a brother or a sister whoever it may be
coming into the scene
and helping my cause now
when i see brother muhammad hijab will
be
whoever it may be when they come to the
tower i rejoice i should rejoice and i
should be happy why
because you're helping the cause you are
helping my cause
i personally without any
sounding like i'm doing something
special because this is the get-go this
is how every single one of us should be
but because of the times we live in you
might see this as something praiseworthy
it's not
i was happy i was like sent a brother
who can help me who can help the
religion who can maybe help himself by
getting involved in doubt because when
you're involved in that
it protects me from certain sins etc you
have to be happy
i should be happy when i see another
believer
defending the kalam of allah now if i
have a problem with that
i have to question my heart why do i not
like this brother what's the reason
what is the reason i need to ask this
question to myself
and this is very important muhammad ibn
said i do not envy anyone for some wordy
thing
for if he is going to be amongst the
people of paradise then how can i envy
him
for something of the worldly life whilst
he is destined for paradise
and if he is going to be amongst the
people of the hellfire then how can i
envy him for something of the worldly
life
while he is destined for the hell fire
now this issue here is not just
okay you know it's a problem in the
heart no this is
this involves tawheed this involves you
denying allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala's
decree your your basic
your problem when you have a jealous
when you have jealousy with anybody
your problem is actually not with that
person your problem
is is with your lord because you're
saying the following
i have a problem and i am jealous and i
do not like the fact that this brother
is more knowledgeable than me
i do not like the fact that this brother
has more money than me i don't like the
fact that this brother is more good
looking than me or sister it might be
sister
as well i do not like the fact that this
brother's got this this
who is the one that's bestowing that to
him the old sustainer allah subhanahu
wa'tala yeah
so now your beef yeah in real terms i'll
tell you
is not with that person your problem
with is with allah
is with allah you're saying allah i have
a problem with
you giving this person this so
it's a matter of tawheed you need to
understand that
that allah is the provider and he can
bestow whatever
whatever he likes on whomever he likes
and the fact that you're questioning
that
is a very very big problem now even
have mercy on him has said the following
that envy is broken up to three
sections the first type is the following
the type is very little
the type is this type is very little and
does not leave the envia to harm others
either by way of hatred in his heart
speech of the tongue
or deeds of the hand rather the person
has some envy in his heart
but he only deals with his muslim
brother through what allah loves
this is something that is not harmful so
me personally my way of
dealing with this is the following if
any time now i'm not going to try
everybody has some kind of jealousy now
that they've been telling me allah said
yeah
you're going to have some kind of
jealousy it's how you control it
so for example if any time i feel some
kind of thing in my heart towards any
kind of brother or sister
i do three things yeah number one
i seek refuge in allah from the curse
jaitan shaytan
that's number one number two i make dua
for that person
and say oh allah increase this brother
or increase his sister
higher than myself and give him the best
in this life in the hereafter and the
third thing that i do is the following
when i'm in a gathering i will praise
him
and if i'm in the gathering this goes
with anyone not just prophet muhammad
anyone this is the my personal this is
me personally to me yeah
my way of dealing with the shaytan
whispers
whispering these kind of jealousy
thoughts to me i'm trying to say
this is alhamdulillah praiseworthy thing
why
because you're what you're doing is
that you're controlling you're
acknowledging and saying this is a
disease in the heart
how do i deal with it this is a good
trait rather than using
how can i ignite this further and try to
cause
some kind of physical harm or you know
some people go to the levels of doing
magic
they go to and they get involved that's
how much you know they they they hate
the person
now the second type even kaim talks
about
the envy decides that the blessing
bestowed on the one he envies
should cease should stop he hates that
allah should give blessings to his
slaves
rather he decides that the envied person
should remain in that state
of deprivation yeah this is obviously
something that is haram
yeah you should not do this third type
is
it is when a person wishes to be like
another person
without desiring that the blessings
possessed by that person should cease
the person who has this type of envy is
not blamed rather this is very similar
to praiseworthy competition to excel and
another another in good deeds
beautiful example yeah they competed
with each other in what
righteousness good deeds yeah
this is what they did this is not blame
worthy
shaykh uthaimin has said the 13
things that come the effects of jealousy
the harmful effects of jealousy okay so
the first is it is from the major sins
which is not
expiated by uh the way of salah
fasting charity or any other deed rather
it requires the individual to make
tawba you have to make specific toba for
this so it's not something
that you know we say you know says in
the quran if you do righteously you know
it would
um um like allah says
get rid of your mind sins yeah this is
something that's a medicine that
requires for you to personally repent
and the condition of repentance that you
hate the sin you stop the sin and you
try not to
go back to the sin but if it involves
wronging another person you have to ask
their forgiveness
so that's the first thing the second
thing is there is a severe punishment it
has been narrated from the prophet peace
be upon him
beware of envy because envy confirms
destroys virtues such as
the fire consumes firewood yeah
the third is that it is from the
mannerisms of certain
jewish people and maybe the traits that
uh they are referred as banu and who
likes to be described with an attribute
from the attributes
of certain uh banu israel certain
uh bad jews yeah we have bad and good in
every
faith just put that context fourth
it negates the brotherhood of faith
because the envy wishes for the
blessings of allah to cease
and the believer loves for his brother
what he lost for himself as we know the
prophet
said love for your brother what you love
for yourself the fact that you're
jealous is you
you're you're negating you don't want
that to happen
fifthly negation of being pleased with
qaddaf the divine
um execution and qatar divine will of
allah if he was pleased with
kada and qadhar he would have said that
this is from allah
and it is good yeah that's the sixth
point
the seventh point is the envy follows
the footsteps of shaytan
yeah what did the shaytan do when adam
is created
i am better than him yes
so much so the one who and he acquires
allah
um exists allah is asking him to do
something he rejected based on why
you favored him more than me
and allah says in surah verse 21 all you
who believe follow not the footsteps of
shaytan
eighth point jealousy inheritance
inherits enemies and hatreds between the
people
yeah you cause fitnah yeah ninth
jealousy leads to injustice oppression
adam's son assaulted and killed his
brother because of jealousy
the tenth point the envy has disdain for
the blessings of allah so he doesn't
recognize any blessings of allah upon
him
for this you find those virtuous
individuals from allah bestowed upon
blessings
do not have the sickness because they
recognize the blessings
jealousy is only found in one who
doesn't see
any of allah's blessings upon himself
what this means is
that you're so indulged and thinking all
you know why does this person have this
why is it you're so busy with that
subhanallah that you don't see the
blessing that was bestowed upon you
you're you're too busy with other people
why is he got this why is it that why is
that why do i have this
and your what's going to happen you're
not going to recognize and see
you know the things that allah has
blessed you with point 11
it decreases iman it decreases your
faith alhamdulillah how could you not
decrease your faith
when you're forgetting the remembrance
of allah you're forgetting this liquor
and you're too busy
concentrating he's got this he's got
that why do i have it 12 point
his heart is busy it connects 12 11 and
12.
his heart is visited from the
remembrance of allah and his heart
becomes hard because of this
supernova what great of a punishment
else there can be that you
are too busy not remembering allah but
you're too jealous
of what was bestowed on another person
point 13
lastly he consumes the blessings of
allah and covers up good qualities of
others
you find one of them when someone they
envy is mentioned with something good
they say this is correct this is good
mashallah
he is beneficial to people but then
after that he mentions some faults
to keep him down and we have to ask to
protect us from that yeah
so we have um
and from the evil of an envia when he
envies
yeah so allah has even given us given us
a verse of revelation
and the evils of those who envy yeah and
you know the process of selling before
we'd go to three narrated by ashraf
that you recite blow in his hand
and wipe it over his body and um
i've asked my teachers and they said
that you can do that you know in
different times as well it's not just
for before you go back so in a nutshell
brother and sister i just want to wrap
up
inshallah i hope you guys have benefited
from this and understood and i highly
recommend for you guys to actually send
this to people that might benefit those
who are studying abroad
whoever it may be yeah because this is a
disease that covers our ummah and sadly
it covers it so bad that there's people
out there that are looking for the
faults and the downfall of other
believers
just so they can feed their ego and say
oh see i knew it you know
while i said this is in the heart yeah
and we asked allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
to bring more people into the dhawa
scene that would help the kalam of allah
defend it against his enemies
and we ask allah to protect us from
jealousy and envy towards those people
and we ask allah to increase them in
their goodness
and alhamdulillah how could a believer
not be happy towards another believer
that is doing the works of
islam and alhamdulillah promoting islam
allah's religion further
i hope you guys have benefited inshallah
and sisters may allah bless you guys
inshallah
and inshallah i ask you guys to make dua
that allah keeps us humble
because over praise like the prophet
sallam said that if someone praises you
throw dust in their face because you're
actually breaking their back
you're literally and i've seen this from
my i'll be honest with you brother and
sister i've seen people that i've worked
with before
being praised to a level where i can
when i heard this
hadith i said well i can see that
happening in front of me you're breaking
the guys back
you're you're giving this and we are all
people in the public scene
we are in danger of this when we're
overly
praised we start thinking we are
something special and how many people
have we seen that's gonna strike because
of this so we ask allah protect us
inshallah and all praise his glory and
gratitude belongs to him
until next time assalamu alaikum
warahmatullahi